>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Good afternoon.
Buenas tardes.
My name is Georgette
Dorn and I'm the head
of the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress.
It is a great pleasure to
welcome this wonderful symposium
to the library and a great
honor for the Hispanic Division
to have you all here,
and especially welcome is
Professor Serge Gruzinski,
who is an eminent historian.
The Hispanic Division
is the home of 170--
The library has 170
million items.
Of those, 14 million
relate to up
to Latin America,
Spain and Portugal.
The Hispanic Division is
also the home of the Handbook
of Latin American Studies,
which is a scholarly resource
to study Latin America.
It is also the home
of the Archive
of Hispanic Literature on Tape.
We have recorded 750 authors
until today and we're adding 50
of those a year online.
Welcome. Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ralph Bauer: Thank
you, Georgette.
Thank you all for coming on this
[inaudible] Friday afternoon
in the last day of March.
I'm Ralph Bauer.
I'm at the University
of Maryland
and I'm currently the convener
of the Early Americas Working
Group, which is a group
of local Early Americanists
that coordinates
and organizes events relating
to the early Americas.
So it's my distinct pleasure
to welcome you to the symposium
"Mestizaje, Hybridity and
Cultural Entanglements
in Colonial Latin America"
with a keynote addressed
by Serge Gruzinski.
First of all, I'd like
to thank Georgette Dorn
and Talia Guzman-Gonzalez
and the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress,
as well as the Hispanic
Cultural Society
for hosting this event today.
Also, I'd like to thank the
Kislak Family Foundation
for their generous
support of this symposium,
as well as of our initiatives,
the group's initiatives here
over the last several years.
And of course, also, I'd like to
thank the Early Americas Working
Group for helping to
co-organize this event.
Finally, also the University
of Maryland at College Park
for their administrative
support.
So, we're going to proceed
in two different panels today
and then those will be--
We'll take a break in
between the two panels
and then we'll finally conclude
with our keynote
address at the end.
So I think-- Are we all
set with the PowerPoints?
That's great.
OK. So I think we'll just stick
with the original order then.
So our first speaker
today in the first panel,
which will be dealing with
Mesoamerica in the first panel,
our first speaker will be Joan
Bristol, an associate professor
of history at George
Mason University.
She's the author of numerous
articles that have appeared
in edited collections
and such journals
as "Boletín del Archivo General
de la Nación" and the "Journal
Of Colonialism And
Colonial History" as well
as of a monograph entitled,
"Christians, Blasphemers,
and Witches: Afro-Mexican
Ritual Practice
in the Seventeenth
Century" which was published
by the University of New
Mexico Press in 2007.
She's now working on a
new book about pulque.
And I think this presentation
is drawn from that new project
as her presentation is
entitled "Mixing Pulque
and Drinking Coyotes
in Colonial Mexico".
So, Joan.
>> Ralph?
>> Ralph Bauer: Yes.
[Inaudible] Maybe
later for the Q&A.
>> All right.
We're ready.
So--
>> Joan Bristol: OK.
Which one?
Thank you very much for coming.
Thank you, Ralph,
for inviting me
and I'm really happy to be here.
Today I'm going to talk
about the way that pulque,
a fermented beverage, was used
as a way to talk about race
and especially about indigeneity
in the colonial period in Mexico
in a way that has
resonance for the present.
And I should say that the
remarks are drawn from a chapter
that I wrote for
an edited volume
that I think Marcy [assumed
spelling] wrote the introduction
for, called "Substance and
Seduction: Ingested Commodities
in Colonial Mesoamerica, the
Atlantic World and Beyond"
which was edited by Kathryn
Sampeck and Stacy Schwarzkopf.
So it will be coming
out in print.
But it's also a work in progress
because it is part
of a larger book.
So, pulque is an alcoholic
beverage, which is made
by fermenting the sap
of the maguey plant,
which is also called the agave,
and here we have a picture.
And then this is--
And then this is a--
This is a picture
of a [inaudible],
a person who is taking the
sap from the maguey plant
through a gourd and then the
sap will be made into pulque.
Mesoamericans have been drinking
pulque for probably millennia.
There is some debate
about how old it is.
Although its popularity has
waxed and waned, particularly
in the past hundred years or so.
Pulque is quite perishable
so it usually only last
for a few days, maybe
up to a week
after it's finished fermenting.
Although recently some
companies have begun canning it
for export.
And so here we have
Pulque La Lucha,
and we'll come back to that.
The alcohol level varies,
so I think it can be
as low as 2 to 3% alcohol.
I looked at public health
records from the early nine--
the early 20th century in
Mexico City, and there,
the alcohol content
seemed to be like 3 to 4%.
I think that this canned
pulque is 5% alcohol.
So probably for as long as
people have been talking
about pulque, they've
been arguing about issues
of moderation and abuse.
So in the 1540s, friar
Toribio de Motolinia said
that pulque made indigenous
people "violently drunk
and accordingly more
cruel and bestial".
Although he then went on
to say, actually, however,
if taken with moderation,
pulque is wholesome
and very nutritious.
And this is this
contrast you see
in a lot of-- I have
many examples.
So you can see here
in this quotation,
in addition to the issues
of moderation and abuse,
you can see that Spaniards,
as well as indigenous people saw
this as an indigenous product
that was consumed by indigenous
people, although in fact
like everybody drink it in
many different settings.
This multilinea quotation
also points to the fact
that colonial chroniclers
tended to discuss pulque
through categories of
order and disorder,
purity and mixture
and health and vice.
So as Mary Douglas and
others have explained,
these sorts of ideas
about purity
and pollution are often
used to maintain boundaries
and reinforce social
hierarchies.
And this connection
between purity
and social order is
particularly obvious
in colonial debates
over mixed pulque.
So, pulque sellers mixed pulque
with all kinds of things,
with fruit, with meat,
occasionally with peyote
and with herbs and
different kinds of roots.
And so for Spanish
officials, pure pulque,
which they called pulque blanco
or like literally white pulque,
pulque blanco was tolerable.
I mean, sort of more or less
tolerable in different times,
but overall, generally
tolerable.
But mixing it with
anything made it bad
in the eyes of Spanish
officials.
As early as 1529, Spanish
officials prohibited the sale
of pulque mixed with
any other ingredient
and this regulation continued
throughout the colonial period.
So viceregal decrees of 1535,
1671 and 1792 prohibited
yellow pulque and which--
and they called yellow
pulque corrupt.
And they defined this yellow
pulque as having "the root,
the raiz that strengthens
it, causing drunkenness
that is dangerous to health
and to good customs and from
which come the crimes,
sins, and abominations
that we see continually."
So these decrees proclaimed
that public stands must sell
only pulque that was "pure
and clean" of all confection,
mixture, root or corruption.
And the root that
they were talking
about was palo de timbre.
And this is well
not-- like I googled.
I googled palo de
timbre and this came
up on a culinary website.
So this is a plant that is still
used to speed up fermentation.
And according to this culinary
website, all different parts
of it can be used to speed
fermentation, still are used.
So it could be the leaves,
it could be the branches.
So I don't know, when they
say raiz or root, I don't know
if they're really
talking about the root
or if the branch maybe was used.
It don't look like a
root, but they're talking
about this palo de timbre.
So, palo de timbre was
mentioned in many other texts,
including the 1681 Recopilación
de leyes de los reinos de
Indias, the compilation
of the colonial laws.
And the Recopilación warned
against the damaging effects
of "introducing ingredients
to pulque that are noxious
to spiritual and
temporal health".
Legislators describe the
Indian practice of "mixing it
with certain roots, boiling
water and lime which makes it
so strong that it makes them,
indigenous people,
lose their senses".
Then they went on--
"Then being alienated,
they commit idolatries,
make ceremonies
and Gentile sacrifices."
So it's not just that Spanish
officials tolerated the
consumption of pure
or white pulque,
but they actually made money
from its sale, so they had like,
you know, skin on the game.
In 1668, the crown established
the asiento de pulque.
They named an administrator
to collect pulque taxes.
And then in 1763,
pulque taxation became
the responsibility
of the Real Hacienda
or the royal treasury.
So this seems somewhat
paradoxical.
So if collecting tax money was
the primary concern of crown
and viceregal authorities,
why would they ban the sale
of mixed pulque, from which
they could also make money?
So it's not surprising
that officials would want
to prohibit the sale of pulque
with like things like peyote
or maybe other kinds
of materials
that had obvious
pharmacological properties.
And in fact Daniel Nemser, who
has written about these issues
for the late 17th century,
has shown that Spaniards
actually thought of pulque
that had been mixed
with certain materials
as fundamentally altered and
different from pulque blanco.
So he quotes a theologian
as using the term
transubstantiate
to talk about this.
So this is a material
that's totally different.
But we might ask what's the
problem with adding fruit
or meat or other kind--
you know, adulterating it
in other kinds of ways.
So the fact that officials were
not profiting from all pulque
but were in fact trying to
discourage the consumption
of some pulque suggest that
pulque regulations have to do
with concerns that were
not strictly financial.
So I want to suggest
that the reason
that Spanish officials
prohibited mixed pulque was
at least in part because
of its mixed nature.
So we know very well
that Spaniards valued
purity of blood.
So to have high status or
to occupy certain positions,
you had to prove that you had
limpieza de sangre or, you know,
translated as purity of blood.
Meaning, really,
that you could prove
that you are an old Christian
but it's sort of in--
in sort of in fact kind of meant
that you could prove
you're of European descent.
Presumably, Spaniards also look
for purity in the substances
that went into physical bodies.
And so my favorite example
to describe this conjunction
of ideas about pulque and
ideas about blood lineage comes
in a set of responses to a
survey of drinking habits
that the viceregal
government sent out in 1783.
And so there is a survey, what
do you drink, what's it made
out of, when do you drink it.
And so this yielded a great list
of alcoholic drinks, you know,
saying where these things were
drunk and what went into them
and this kind of thing.
And so most of these
recipes were sort
of neutrally explanatory.
So, for example, to make a drink
that is called mantequilla,
which in this period I think
would translate literally
as lard.
I don't know why it's
called mantequilla.
But informants reported that
they "mixed" aguardiente
or distilled alcohol,
and pulque and sugar
or some other sweetener.
So this was a mixture but
this is reported in a sort
of matter of fact way.
In this list, a drink
called coyote stands out.
So, coyote was "composed of
inferior pulque, dark honey
and palo de timbre," this plant,
"and putting it in an infusion,
it gets stronger and people
drink it although it's
very harmful".
And the term is nocivo.
The term always-- I
translated it I think as noxious
at one point and then I
translated it as harmful
but it's always-- it's
almost always nocivo.
So that's interesting.
You know that this word is
like through the century sort
of repeated in relation to
this mixed, mixed pulque.
So the name of this
drink, this--
the name coyote is striking.
In the eight-- as
you I'm sure know--
In the 18th century the
term coyote was used
to describe a person of mixed
descent, theoretically one
who is three quarters indigenous
and one quarter Spanish.
So liquid coyote-- and OK, I did
have a slide, I can remember.
So liquid coyotes and human
coyotes then were both
characterized by mixture.
So the description of the
beverage coyote as harmful
and low grade recall some
contemporary Spanish ideas
that castas or people of
mixed racial background,
including so called
coyotes were inferior,
dangerous and disorderly.
So in 1763, the Capuchin
chronicler Francisco de Ajofrín
wrote, "lobos, [inaudible]
and coyotes,"
these are these categories
of mixed people,
"are fierce people
of bizarre customs."
This is not the only kind
of depiction of these castas
or these mixed people.
So I brought these
caste paintings
because they show people
drinking pulque so you can sort
of see what it might have,
you know, been like in action.
But you can also see that these
are paintings of mixed people
but they show the sort of
harmonious family unit.
And then those of you to whom
I spoke before this know--
and was like sort of confused
because the caste painting
that we have on our program
today actually doesn't have
[inaudible] so I don't
know what that means,
but we can talk about that.
So the connection
between lineage--
sorry, liquids and
lineage is clear
in the 1611 Spanish dictionary
in which the noun mezcla
or mixture was defined as
"the incorporation of a liquid
with another" and its verb form,
this dictionary defined mezclar,
the verb to mix as meaning
"to unite diverse things".
And then the example
was "to mix lineages
when some lineages are mixed
up with others that are not
of the same calidad or quality".
The dictionary went on to say--
and we say it is a thing
without mixture when it's pure.
So, purity, mixture, process.
Calidad use-- the word
used in the 1611 dictionary
in a general way, meaning sort
of quality or type was also used
to indicate social status
in the colonial period.
So there are several ways to
approach the Spanish fears
about these mixed drinks.
So first, these kind of--
these rules in legislation
reflect a sort
of material solution
to fears about mixing.
So Spanish officials feared
that the mixing of liquids
and other ingredients
in pulque drinks
because of resulting inebriation
could lead to the mixing
of bodies, and ultimately the
mixing of blood, both in terms
of like the bloodshed
that comes from violence,
and also the mixing of
lineages that could, you know,
happen when people had
sex with each other
and had kids together.
So possibly through pulque
fuel the sexual relations.
So we've seen example of
these in the ban of sales
of all pulque after the 1692
bread riots in Mexico City.
So in this-- right after
these riots, officials claimed
that the insurrection had
been planned in pulquerias
and then they banned
pulque briefly.
There was like a little bit of
a disagreement between the crown
and the viceregal government.
And Daniel Nemser, this person I
have mentioned before has talked
in at length about this-- he
wrote an article about this.
He said the study of mixed
pulque offered a lead
to language for talking
about race mixing, mestizaje,
while simultaneously
constituting pulque consumers
as a seditious collective
subject, a plebe defined,
like pulque, by mixing.
So he's talking about
this issue in this period.
So as Nemser's work indicates,
this worry about mixing pulque
was also a manifestation
of biopower, biopolitics
in the way
that Foucault has
talked about it.
So by claiming to
protect colonial residents
from the disorderly
effects of mixing pulque,
the state was trying to control
their bodies and their actions
and it was then also
another way to sort
of perpetuate this discourse as
of-- about mixing as undesirable
and corrupting and bad.
Spanish officials
were not only worried
about Spanish identity
being adulterated, however,
but they were also worried
about indigenous identity
being adulterated.
And we see this like
all over the place.
So we see this in regular
decrees prohibiting Spaniards,
blacks and castas, mixed people,
from living in indigenous
villages.
And we also see this in
the two republic idea,
the idea that the colonial
world should be split up sort
of juridically and
also spatially
into the republica de indios
and the republica de Espanol.
Although it's like only a
fantasy, it never works.
So, ideas about pure
Indianness and pure pulque
and the importance of
maintaining the purity
of both were linked in crown
and viceregal policies
limiting the sale
of the permitted white
pulque to indigenous sellers.
Decrees from 1608, 1635 and
1639 restricted licenses
for selling pulque
to indigenous women,
although in practice
Spaniards, as well as men
of different groups were
involved in the trade
in Mexico City certainly by the
18th century or possibly before.
Religious leaders were
specifically worried
about Spanish cultural
polluting indigenous people.
In the mid 16th century,
the friar Diego Duran condemned
mixed pulque writing "today,
what is called pulque made by
Spaniards from the black honey
and water with the root
in it was never known
to the ancients," meaning sort
of the Nahua people
before contact.
He's writing in Central Mexico.
"Nor do they know how to
concoct it until the blacks
and Spaniards invented it."
And so this seems to be
the recipe for coyote
that we see later, much later,
200 years later in the 179--
in the 1783 text that
I talked about earlier.
Duran and-- goes on to
describe white pulque
as "their own native wine"
which is lighter and medicinal,
meaning Nahua people's
native wine,
and then describes this
mixed variant as "diabolical,
stinking, black, potent, rough,
without flavor or taste".
So, again, so mixture makes
pulque diabolical while white
pulque is both purely indigenous
and better and more wholesome
but also kind of
rooted in the past.
In the 1634 Nahua to
confession manual,
Bartolome de Alva addressed
indigenous Mexicans directly.
I mean, sort of, lamenting
that "for a gourd of pulque,
or a cup of wine, you
cast your souls to hell
and give them to the devil."
And he claimed that before
contact with Spaniards,
Nahua people, "had
discretion, prudence, fear,
shame and good breeding,
but he said that now they
had been turned into beasts
by drunkenness and
intoxication."
So he wrote, "even though the
ancients, your elders, drink--
excuse me, it was with
moderation and restraint
as your neighbors, the
Spaniards, do today."
Which I don't really know
what to make of that but--
And if by some chance
they sometimes they used
to discover some drunkard,
they immediately took
away his life for it.
And now in our times, it exists
because nobody restrains you
with the death penalty.
And this is actually in
reference to this idea
that comes from the Florentine
Codex that under the Aztecs,
the drinking of pulque
was restricted
to ritual specialists
and the elderly.
Although it seems that this
was-- this never really--
This was not really the
case, but there is this--
people think that
this is the case.
So Duran and Alva then
were idealizing the past,
this Nahua past, and using
pulque as a way to argue
for the need to protect
but really
to regulate native bodies.
Yet in reality, of course,
people and practices
were actively mixing
in all kinds of ways.
Friar Ilarione da Bergamo,
who is an Italian Capuchin
who dropped-- traveled
in New Spain
in the 1760s described
maguey in this way.
So, maguey, the plant, right,
from which pulque comes.
So he says, as you can read,
this plant is also held
in special esteem by the
Most Blessed Virgin Mary
because in the year
1540 she appeared
to an Indian named Juan
de Aguila on the hill
of Totoltepec, which is not far
from Mexico City, and told him
that he should look for her
image in the very same place.
After initial efforts he
found in the middle of one
of these plants a small
statute of the Blessed Virgin
with her babe in her arms
though it's not known
from what material it is made.
The Mexicans showed great faith
and devotion to this and in time
of greatest need they have
a special recourse to it
through public prayers.
So what does this sound like?
It sounds like the Virgin
of Guadalupe, right?
So the Virgin of Guadalupe just
nine years before had appeared
to Juan Diego at Tepeyac
and she, you know,
appears in this hill
where Tonantzin was
important, this earlier deity.
This description also calls to
Mayahuel, who is the goddess
of maguey and pulque depicted
in both the Codex Mendoza
and then here of an image
from the Codex Borgia,
as a woman with 400 breasts
nursing a baby while sitting
in a maguey plant.
And so, you know, this is how
it's been interpreted, so.
However, pulque was pragmatic--
was hybrid in a more
pragmatic way as well.
So it's hybrid just because
lots of people drink it
in many different situations.
So the same Italian friar wrote,
today consumption of pulque is
so widespread that
everyone drinks it.
There are public pulquerias,
which are like our
public wine shops.
A few years ago, it was not
proper for people with any kind
of social standing
to go into them
because entering a place
frequented only by drunks
and by rabble of
every ilk seemed
to undercut their
respectability.
Now, people of every
rank frequent them,
and during the time
of my stay in Mexico,
I observed many carriages and
coaches of gentlemen, ladies,
merchants and other respectable
people heading to these places.
And this is my favorite part.
As for myself, in the roughly
five years that I resided
in that country, I could not
get used to drinking that liquor
because of its foul odor.
Even though Europeans,
after drinking it for two
or three days became
even more keen on it
than the local population
itself.
So Bergamo here is obviously
participating in the sort
of discourse that sees Spanish
creoles as sort of degraded
because of their
American origins.
But it's also interesting
because it shows--
and he's saying in this
period but I think it's true
or it's definitely true early as
well that pulque consumption was
of course not only limited
to indigenous people.
However, much the discourse
about pulque revolved
around identifying them as
the primary pulque drinkers.
So ultimately, I'm
interested in the way
that this colonial
pulque discourse may
or may not foreshadow
ideas about indigeneity
and Mexican identity in the
19th, 20th, and 21st centuries.
So after 21-- I'm sorry,
after 1821, caste distinctions
and ethnic privileges and
protections were abolished
by liberal policymakers.
After 1910, mixture
was celebrated.
The idea the Indian as part
of the cosmic race
really became a linchpin
for Mexican national
identity and the idea here was
that the Indian was part
of the past while the
mestiza was the future.
And I should say going
back to the 19th century,
Deborah Toner has written
this wonderful book,
which I can't remember
the name of,
but about the representations
of alcohol and drunkenness
and the relationship to national
identity in the 19th century.
So that's very good book.
But so the modern-- In
the modernization products
of the early to mid
20th century,
pulque sort of fell behind.
So the state actually
encourages beer consumption
over pulque consumption.
Beer was taxed less heavily.
There weren't as many
hygienic regulations.
The state was subsidizing
some of the beer producers.
And in part, this is because
it's seen as sort of modern
and progressive and clean,
and pulque is characterized
as not clean in this period.
Now in the 21st century,
pulque is having a resurgence
as middleclass students and all
kinds of people go to pulquerias
and it's very, very hip.
That's the word that-- and so
it was used to describe it.
So the New York Times and the
LA Times have had articles
in their travel sections within
the past five years or so
which emphasize how
pulque is sort
of the symbol of Mexicanness.
So much of the current
pulque discourse revolves
around defining Mexico through
a purely indigenous past.
And so here we have
again Pulque La Lucha.
This is advertised, as you
can see it down there in that
like ribbon on the bottom, it
says it's older than tequila,
stronger than beer, it's the
original drink of Mexico.
And the website go-- It
claims that the drink
"survived the ravages
of the European invaders
for three centuries
prior to the formation
of the Republic of Mexico."
And I guess none of these
things are really not--
are untrue, you know, but it--
but it's sort of the
way they're using it
to advertise, it's interesting.
The New York Times
describes pulque
in one these travel
articles, it's "a thick
and pungent 2000 year
old Aztec drink."
We know the Aztecs were
not 2000 years old.
And "a toast to the Aztec gods."
So I'll end by saying
that it's tempting
to see historical continuities
between the colonial
and modern idealizations
of indigenous identity
and the effort to
discursively define Indians
as pure in both cases.
And that was really where
my emphasis lay, I think,
when I first started
thinking about this.
But when we examine this more
closely, we see a rupture
with the colonial past as well.
Today's pulque discourse
emphasizes the mixed nature
of Mexican identity and in many
ways relegates its indigenous
identity to the past.
However, throughout
the colonial period,
indigenous people
were a central concern
of the Spanish colonial
authorities and one of the ways
that Spanish authorities try
to contain indigenous
people and their economics.
Sorry, and their economic
activities was specifically
through this pulque discourse.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ralph Bauer: OK.
I'd like to hold the questions
until the end of the panel.
So we'll proceed right
to the next speaker
who will be Garry Sparks who
is an Assistant Professor
of Religious Studies at
George Mason University.
His research and teaching
focus on anthropological
and socio-cultural
and linguistic as well
as ethnohistorical
understandings
of theological production
in the Americas,
particularly among
indigenous peoples.
His areas include histories
of Christian thought
and the theories of
religion and culture,
religions of indigenous
American peoples,
and the religion
in Latin America.
Since 1995, he has done
human rights work with
and conducted fieldwork among
the Highland Maya in Guatemala
and Chiapas in Mexico.
His first book, "The Americas'
First Theologies: Early Sources
of Post-Contact Indigenous
Religion" is forthcoming
from Oxford University Press
in August of this year.
He is currently revising his
second book, "Domingo de Vico,
K'iche' Maya Intellectuals,
and the Theologia Indorum:
Recovering the Legacy of the
Americas' First Theology,"
which is under contract,
to be published
with the University
Press of Colorado.
And also, he is completing
with the support of the NEH,
Scholarly Translation
and critical addition
of the Theologia Indorum, which
will be published in 2020.
His titled-- His talk
today is entitled,
Religiously Appropriating
Indios:
20th- and 16th-Century
Theological Production from
and by...well, Indios.
>> Garry Sparks: Great.
Many thanks.
The title is supposed to be
somewhat of a double entendre
which I hope will become a
little more clear as we proceed.
And if you had never heard of
the Theologia Indorum before
in Ralph's nice introduction,
I'll unpack that as well.
Based on the use of the term,
since at least the medieval era
and the application or perhaps
better said, the misapplication
of Indorum to the Americas,
it served as a catchall phrase
for all fantastic objects
from an exotic land,
namely its flora, fauna and
peoples, and by extension,
their rights, customs and laws.
Accompanied with the
emergence of the Spanish Empire
and its ideology of clean
or pure blood, the category
of Indio was further relegated
to a pejorative status socially,
politically, as well
as theologically.
And much of the history is
own religion in Latin America
by focusing on records of
the out of the phase tale
of early missionaries'
preoccupation for the endurance
of indigenous religions as
forms of idolatry, witchcraft
or heresy, especially when
seen as mixed with Christianity
and thus akin to a
spiritual mysticism.
As a result, many cultural
theories even those sympathetic
to native peoples like
postcolonialism tend
to relegate indigenous people to
the options of a simple binary,
of only being either
overly-romanticized reactionary
resistors or passive victims
who are simply coerced
into a new religion.
Thus ironically such
binary options limit
and undervalue the agency and
reasoning of indigenous peoples,
both historically and presently.
And yet on the other hand,
the early paper trail written
in indigenous languages
by both missionaries
and early indigenous
peoples also drew from--
oh, excuse me, evinces a
more complex engagement
of where native peoples and
mendicant missionaries also drew
from the world views of the
proverbial other to reconfigure,
if not also translate
and maintain their own.
Now among the earliest of these
documents of course written
by the Highland Maya
in particular
in Quechan languages is
the Popol Vuh which serves
for Mayanists and indigenous
activists as a cornerstone
within a larger body of early
Native American literature.
However, the references
to Christianity have remained
a perennial puzzle leading some
scholars to argue that the Maya
authors were resisting either
Spanish Christendom at large
or the specific practices
of missionaries in
general, such as preaching
or doctrinal teaching.
And most of this confusion
lies in the opening lines.
The dates of the Popol Vuh
if you're not familiar,
redaction dates are
1554 to 1558.
And the first line of the Popol
Vuh, the K'iche' authors state
that their text is "the root
of the ancient word",
the ojer tzij.
Only to then juxtapose
their ancient word
with what they refer to a
few lines later as the talk
about god, uch'ab'al Dios.
In this way, the K'iche'
authors used Christianity
and the missionaries "talk about
god" as a foil against which
to reassert a pre-contact
Maya cosmology.
However, the specific phrase
uch'ab'al Dios was not coined
by the K'iche redactors
of the Popol Vuh,
but rather they lifted it
from among the writings
of a Dominican friar,
specifically Domingo de Vico.
In other words, rather than
merely referring to Christianity
in general in this opening
preamble of the Popol Vuh,
by this phrase the authors
of the Popol Vuh indicate
that they have read and
are responding directly
to the first theology
written in the Americas,
Vico's Theologia Indorum.
Of the early mendicant
missionaries,
Domingo de Vico compiled
the first important works
on numerous Mayan languages
after arriving into the Americas
in 1544 with over 40 other
Dominican missionaries
and Bartolome de las Casas.
Within a short time, Vico is
said to have learned no less
than seven different
Mayan languages.
And one year prior to
his death, in 1555,
he completed his
Theologia Indorum,
a theology for the Indians
or theology of the Indians.
Consisting of almost
1000 manuscript pages,
divided into 218 chapters
across two distinct volumes,
Vico's Theologia Indorum
addresses a variety
of theological, moral
and cultural issues.
And while no first generation
or even complete
manuscript has survived,
a positively identified
a now 17 partial versions
in at least three, if not
five different Highland Maya
languages which allow
for a complete reconstruction
of the full text.
This is simply a chart of the
size of those manuscripts,
so more or less, where
they reside mostly
in Paris and Princeton.
As one of the first generations
of Spanish students to study
at the University of Salamanca
after the arrival or return
of Francisco de Vitoria
and the establishment
of domestic scholasticism
alongside humanism
as the curricular standard,
Aquinas's Summa Theologiae
serves
as both the general
organizing structure
of Vico's Theologia Indorum
but also the analogical method
by which Vico strove to
reconcile Catholicism
with the Maya world view, much
like Aquinas had centuries prior
but with the Jewish and
Muslim Aristotelianism.
In this compendium
genre of Summa,
Vico presented narrative
summaries of biblical characters
in a stylic and to the
hagiographic stories
of the popular Golden Legend.
For example, volume 1 which
Vico finished in 1553 begins
with the domestic themes of
the names and being of god,
and continues with
stories and lessons
of the Catholic Old Testament
while integrating elements
of Highland Maya
religious material.
The second volume, finished in
early 1554, presents narratives
of the New Testament and
incorporates standard
but much more detailed
than usual catechism material
particularly at a time
when catechisms were
becoming much more simplistic
because indigenous
peoples were deemed
as rudimentary [inaudible],
who just needed
to memorize their rudimentary
material of doctrine.
In contrast, the
contemporaneous mendicant--
to other contemporaneous
mendicant text,
Vico's Theologia Indorum
distinguishes itself
in four important ways.
First, Vico's theology
is not a translation
of a previously written
work elaborated in Europe
and then exported and
translated into Mesoamerica
but rather explicitly
references Maya rituals
and narratives based on his
own direct conversation with
and ethnographic
study among the Maya.
Secondly, the Theologia Indorum
is never in fact ever written,
let alone translated into
Latin or Castilian Spanish,
what was originally
composed in K'iche.
Thirdly, the Theologia Indorum
is the first known work written
in either North or South America
to explicitly declare
itself a theology,
thus intentionally
distinguishing itself in terms
of genre from its textual peers.
And finally, I think
perhaps most importantly,
while apparently commissioned
as an aid for priests,
the primary readers
directly addressed
in Vico's texts are not fellow
clergy but rather literate Maya
to whom he refers as ix, you
all and numi'al, nuk'ajol,
my daughters and my sons,
by which the Theologia
Indorum then emerges
as a direct Christian
reply to the Maya
and their cosmogonic
narratives found
in text like the Popol Vuh.
Now while Vico's obvious aim
pertains to the conversion
of the Maya to Catholicism,
his strategy builds
off an affirmation
of pre-Hispanic Mayan religion.
In Chapter 25, he argued
against the autonomous mixing
of Mayan religious practices
with Catholic devotionalism.
But it does not rule
out altogether a mixing
of Catholic theology and
indigenous devotional practices.
Furthermore, he wrote not
only in the K'iche languages
in which he makes his argument
and assumes a literate
Maya readership
but also used the high register
of Maya ceremonial
discourse typified
by elaborate poetic parallelisms
and archaic turns of phrases
which are traceable to
ancient glyphic text.
A common example of
this is the phrase,
[inaudible] which means
literally, yellowness,
greenness, but it is
more or less a couplet
or lexical parallelism
for wealth,
and we find this actually
in the hieroglyphic text
of the classic period.
Just as notably, Vico
selected motifs and phrases
from Maya theogony also
found in the Popol Vuh.
He chose the Maya term for
the other world Xibalba
that mean hell, and he employed
a Mayan metaphorical language
of weaving and sewing that
we see in the beginning
of the Popol Vuh for his
narrative of cosmogenesis rather
than say, use that
of the biblical book
which is more language
of pottery
and smith making--
metalsmithing.
And he selected terms for his
god, like Tz'aqol, B'itol,
the Maker and the Modeler and
Alom, K'ajolom, the Bearer
and the Begetter over
other phrases also found
in Maya theogony such as
the Sovereign Plumed Serpent
or Heart of Earth, Heart of Sky.
And he even refers to his
Christian god explicitly
as qachuch qaqajaw, our
mother and our father,
thus modifying the
doctrine of god, the father,
as the first person or
persona of the triune deity.
Now, in addition
to the Popol Vuh,
beginning in the early
1550s, most certainly 1552,
Highland Maya began to write
numerous other documents
in their own languages
and exclusively
for their own purposes.
They're not for the crown,
not for the audience.
They are not under
editorial control of clergy.
But in the mendicant
script or alphabet
and employing the
Iberian legal genres,
many of which show
further influence
of both the Theologia
Indorum and the Popol Vuh.
The Title of Totonicapan
is arguably the third most
important K'ichean text.
And the first seven folios, 14
pages, consist of a redaction
of key chapters directly
from the first volume
of the Theologia
Indorum and even list
and cites the specific
chapter numbers used beginning
with Chapter 30 and
the story of Genesis
in the opening line
of this [inaudible].
However, within their
autonomous appropriation
of the Theologia Indorum,
the Title of Totonicapan
further contextualized
or corrected Vico's
theology by, for example,
specifying that Cain was killed
in his [inaudible],
his [inaudible].
And that Moses confronts a
burning Boysenberry Bush,
a toucan, a boundary--
a shrub that's used
as a boundary marker even to
this day among Highland Maya
to distinguish property lines.
Details not in the
Theologia Indorum.
Furthermore, by the eight folio
of the Title of Totonicapan,
the authors of that text begin
to integrate myths also found
in the Popol Vuh as if
to reconcile the pre-Hispanic
Maya religious narratives
with the biblical material
presented by Vico and equating,
for example, the mythical
Mesoamerican city of Tolan
with the biblical
city of Babylon.
Now curiously in contrast with
earlier K'iche writings of 1554,
like the Popol Vuh and
the Title of Totonicapan
which dates most certainly
to 1554, that is to say both
of these texts are
written one year
after Vico finished
the first volume
of his Theologia
Indorum in 1553.
Later independent K'iche
writings actually mentioned Vico
and his Theologia by name.
For example, the third
title of the [inaudible]
which states the
1598 also argues
that the legendary mythological
Maya ancestors made of maize
by the divine grandmother,
Xmukane,
according to the Popol
Vuh, are direct descendants
of the prophets and
the patriarchs listed
in the Catholic Old
Testament as the Title
of the Totonicapan did.
Thus via this supposed land
deed, the K'iche Maya argued
for the validity of their
pre-Hispanic religious
narratives, ritual
practices and authority
by not resisting Hispanic
Catholicism like the authors
of the Popol Vuh did but
rather by grafting onto it.
Furthermore, this
[inaudible] explicitly cites,
if you notice the last
line, it's cited there,
Vico's Theologia Indorum as its
source, which you didn't see
because I didn't advance
the slide, case in point.
Now, unfortunately the
Highland Maya paper trail thins
out after the 1600s.
And while there is no
evidence that clergy outside
of the Guatemala Highlands, say
other Dominicans further North
in Oaxaca, were ever aware of
Vico's theology even there.
Local references [inaudible]
Guatemala and his work
in ecclesial accounts seem to
peer out by the 19th century.
However, as recently as-- by
the mid 1960s, both Catholic
and Protestant clergy
concerned with social issues,
issues of social
justice and areas
with predominantly
indigenous populations,
like Southern Mexico and
the Andean region began
to reevaluate the role and value
of culture in large part due
to the influence of
indigenous activists.
While clergy and theologians,
such as some Dominicans, Jesuits
and Maryknolls but also some
Presbyterians, Methodists
and Lutherans began
to elaborate a--
what's called the theology
of enculturation
alongside the theology
of liberation even prior
to the second Vatican
council in the 1960s.
By the 1970s, indigenous
activists
within various Christian
denominations began
to produce their own
strands of enculturated
or indigenized Christian
theology
through various international,
regional
and highly local workshops aided
by sympathetic clergy
and bishops often.
Indigenous activists helped to
establish an informal network
of centers, curricula and
publications that argue for ways
that indigenous religious world
views can constructively engage
Christian thought and practice.
For example, for various
Highland Maya of Chiapas
and Guatemala, the wives of
Mayan men ordained as deacons
in the Catholic Church also
serve as unofficial deaconesses
in accord with the
cosmogonic principle
of gender complementarity.
I should be very delicate
on this matter because it--
there was an incidence
that was investigated
by then Cardinal Joseph
Ratzinger in the diocese
of San Cristobal de las Casas.
Just-- This is public,
it didn't happen.
The-- And the liturgical
and hagiographic church
calendars are integrated
in many parishes with
the 260 day Mesoamerican
ritual calendar.
Clergy, in many cases Jesuits,
often don't wear habits
or even the Roman color
but rather the attire
of traditional Maya
elders in villages.
The Eucharist I've seen
celebrated on a platter
or patent in the shape
of the back of a turtle,
therefore referencing the
fertile surface of the Earth
as well as the constellation
belt of Orion from which Hunahpu
and Xbalanque emerged with
the resurrected father
as the god of maize.
And in certain services
scripture readings are often
paired with or accompanied
by readings
from the Popol Vuh translated
into other local Mayan languages
such as Tzotzil, Tzeltal and
Q'anjo'bal, thus aligning the
"word of the lord" with the
Maya ancient word, ojer tzij.
As a liberation, this
theological movement,
but in the hands of modern
indigenous intellectuals,
they struggled for a name
that would not separate them
from the class analysis
of liberation theology
or the cultural attentiveness
of enculturation theology,
but simultaneously
would indicate
that their approach was
distinctively indigenous
and one shared in common
across the Americas,
across distinct indigenous
languages, world views
and even national histories
of oppression unique
to native peoples.
In the end, the term that they
thought best indicated their
unique condition of oppression,
historical perspectives
and cultural resources
from which to respond
as indigenous peoples
that all native peoples
in the America shared
was the category, Indios.
And so, they began a two-fold
effort of, one, reappropriating
and redefining on their terms
a pejorative category arguably
much like [inaudible] did with
term mestizo in the 19th century
for the ideology of La Raza
to elaborate a distinctively
but hemispherically
Teologia india.
And two, to begin to specify
a move beyond the category
of Indio for the elaboration
of particular theologies
of distinct peoples like
a particular Maya theology
or even more specific, a K'iche
theology, a Tzeltal theology,
a Q'anjo'bal theology,
Tzotzil theology, et cetera.
What has been proposed
here is not
that there is any direct link
between Vico's Theologia Indorum
and the writings of Highland
Maya elites in the 16th century
and the current efforts
by indigenous peoples
to develop Christian
understandings
on their own cultural
and spiritual terms
in the movement they
called, Teologia India.
In fact I find it quite ironic
that I can literally count
on my hand, actually
a couple of fingers,
the number of academic
Latin Americans involved
in Teologia India who even know
who Vico is or was and neither
of them have actually
read anything by Vico
because they don't know K'iche.
Any explicit textual dots
to connect between the 1550s
and the 1970s is too
vague and spread thin.
So any legacy of Vico lies
not in the written record
of later clergy or Maya but
rather at best implicitly
in the local traditions of
how Maya leaders continued
to navigate between
their indigenous
and their Christian
understandings.
But at the very least, a
thicker ethnohistorical context,
based on intratextual
analysis of the wider corpus
of K'ichean writings
by both mendicants
and Maya provides a
diachronic lens through which
to read current trends in
Latin American religion
and thus further reevaluate
the continued agency
and intellect of, well, Indios.
[ Applause ]
>> Ralph Bauer: Thank
you, Garry.
Our third speaker will be
John Tutino who is a professor
of history and international
affairs as well as the director
of the Americas Initiative
at Georgetown University,
where he focuses on the
history of Mexico in the context
of the Americas in the world,
in particular the history
of popular communities as
they engaged, colonial rule
and early capitalism,
national states
and industrial challenges, as
well as revolutionary promises
and national developments.
He's the author of many
journal articles, book chapters
and books including, "From
Insurrection to Revolution
in Mexico: Social Bases
of Agrarian Violence,
1750 to 1940".
It's published by Princeton
University Press in 1986.
"Making a New World: Founding
Capitalism in the Bajio
and Spanish North
America" published
by Duke University
Press in 2011.
And "The Mexican Heartland: How
Communities Shaped Capitalism,
a Nation, and World
History, 1500 to 2000",
published by Princeton
this year.
The title of his talk
today is, "An Old Regime
and a New Economy: A Dynamic
Balance in Spanish Mesoamerica".
>> John Tutino: Thank you
Ralph for the invitation
and for organizing and to
Georgette for hosting us all.
I come as an enormous
admirer of Serge Gruzinski
from his early essays
to the Man-Gods book,
to colononizacion
de lo imaginario,
to "The Eagle and the Dragon".
I can just I have learned
so much and more important,
always been set to
new ways of thinking.
Early on, he and I focused I
want to say in different ways
but on social-cultural
encounters
in the Mesoamerican core.
More recently, we both
turned to Spain's empire
and its global role,
again, in different ways.
And I want to say
exactly as it should be.
How dull life would be
if we were all doing
things in the same way.
As to speak today, I
quickly came to two goals.
First, I wanted to build on one
of the concepts I most admire
in Serge's work, the
notion of hybridity.
And second, I wanted to take
the chance to offer a preview
and gain some feedback on
some of my work in progress.
As I thought about it,
because when asked for a title,
you come up with what you think
of it the day you're invited.
In certain ways, a better
title of what I want
to do today might be simply
called a hybrid political
economy, Spanish
Mesoamerica from 1550 to 1800.
And this comes out of the
fact that I am in the process
of completing two things.
In fact, while "The Mexican
Heartland" book has a 2017 date
on it, I am-- you have given me
a break from reading the copy
of the manuscript
today so I want
to thank you all for that too.
It will not be out
until November.
And because I have the
copyedited manuscript
in front me, if you straight
me out on something pivotal,
I still have time to tinker.
And I simultaneously have just
finished what hopefully is the
last draft of a manuscript.
I had to get it done
before the copyedits came--
of a book entitled
Mexico City, 1808,
which I tell people is the book
no one will believe Tutino wrote
because it is urban,
political and short [laughter].
And I have never fallen into
any of those traps before.
But I'm trying and I have
succeeded, it's going to publish
to less than 200 pages
of readable text.
So I count it a triumph.
"The Mexican Heartland"
book very much focuses
on the rural communities of
the basins around Mexico City,
precisely to distinguish it
from the Bajio that I wrote
about in making a new world.
The Mexico City book focuses
on a pivotal moment
of regime change.
From what-- And this is
really what I'm going
to focus on today.
From a regime that ruled
primarily by mediation backed
by claims of divine
sovereignty to a lesser regime,
and I want to call
it more a state,
that ruled by military
assertion backed by claims
of popular sovereignty.
And I'm not going to get into
the transition today other
than to say one of the things
the book tries to do is point
out that the shift came in 1808,
before the wars of independence.
The turn is part of the
stimulus to the conflicts.
It is not a result
of the conflicts.
That's not for today.
What I want to emphasize
today is that both projects,
the Mexican Heartland project
and the Mexico City
1808 project,
required me to push forward
on a rethinking of the nature
of the Spanish regime
in New Spain.
Over the long haul, and
particularly prior to 1760
in the coming of the
Bourbon assertions and thus
to rethink the impact
of what we too--
we call the Bourbon reforms
that hit New Spain
hardest from the 1760s.
And my emphasis there is that
that impact was far more limited
than we have often
taken it to be.
But today, I want to focus
on my emerging understanding
of the regime of more
or less 1550 to 1750
and its pivotal role
in sustaining
and stabilizing a silver economy
that funded Spain's empire
that drove global
trades and focusing on it
in what I have dubbed the
Mexican Heartland a region
grounded in enduring
self-governing landed
indigenous communities.
My argument and in
the original title is
that it is an old
regime sustaining,
promoting a new economy.
I use old regime very explicitly
as the English variant
of what Europeans would
call an ancien regime.
An ancien regime tied
to an economy becoming ever more
capitalist and that the fusion
of them is what matters.
And I'm going to argue that both
the ancien regime as it evolved
in New Spain was a hybrid.
The new economy as it evolved
in the Mesoamerican
regions was a hybrid
and thus the fusion
is a double hybrid.
Let me try to make the case.
And you'll quickly see
that I am building upon
and giving my own twist to a lot
of work by colleagues I admire.
So on the ancien regime
following the work
of Alejandro Caneque, following
Ernesto Sanchez de Tagle,
whose work is mostly known
in Mexico, following the work
of Annick Lempérière,
and also following the work
of my colleague Jim Collins
who has argued for decades
that what is called
absolutism in France
and Europe is overunderstood as
coercive and needs to be seen
in very different more
negotiating mediating ways.
I see the regime that emerged
in New Spain after about 1550
as a classic ancien
regime in key ways.
It is based on multiple
corporations
and institutions sanctioned
with multiple rights
and laws integrated and overseen
by a regime that focuses
on mediation, sometimes
judicial, sometimes political,
but everything is
a balancing act.
And it does that and you can
play with the cause and effect
because certainly in the
interior of New Spain,
it is a regime with notably
limited coercive capacities.
It has very little ability to
force anybody to do anything
and thus it turned to force
only as a last resort,
and it understands that
if everything I've said
to that fits the model of the
scholars I have listed I think
in terms of being an Ancien
regime in the New World.
But I want to emphasize, in New
Spain, it is very much a hybrid
because it was grounded in the
creation of literally thousands,
one good Mexican scholar
has had it over 4000,
indigenous republics with rights
to land and self-rule built
on the remnants of the
indigenous altepetl ruled
by native notables
adapting variants
of what I just generically
call indigenous Christianities.
I don't think very far from
where Garry is going here.
And that operate with
sanctioned rights to mediations
through special courts.
What perhaps, this I
offer speculatively,
made this hybrid a
particularly unique variant
of an ancien regime is what--
is really the extreme dearth
of military power on
the ground in New Span.
If-- As my colleague Jim
Collins has detailed,
the French ancien regime
mediated first and coerced only
when pressed when it had to.
There was no dearth of
coercive force in Europe.
War guaranteed that there
were coercive forces around
and available, sometimes one
wonders, a little more dispersed
than we sometimes think.
In New Spain after 1550 in
the Mesoamerican regions,
after 1600 in the end of what
are called the Chichimeca wars
in the Bajio and regions north,
the indigenous majority
was disarmed.
That's famously known.
Less often recognized is the
Spanish regime essentially
disarmed too and
relied on what I had--
best can call minimal
and uncertain malicious.
Certainly not controlled,
funded or commanded
by anybody in the regime.
Now, again, there
were military efforts.
But the Spanish empire's
military activity focused first
on a naval protection
of trade and on holding
in New Spain the far
northern frontiers
and I will quickly note that
in the latter its success was
pretty limited too.
It didn't have all that
much effective force
in the far north as well.
So if I'm right, the question
becomes, how could a regime
with such limited coercive
powers be sustained
for centuries?
And I want to argue, there are
really two key factors looking
behind this.
The first is, I don't
know how else to put it,
the greatest calamity of
contact and conquest was--
became the basis for the
underlying success of the regime
that followed, and that
is the depopulation.
That by the late 16th century,
resources are astonishingly
ample
to a radically shrunken
surviving native populations
organized in the new indigenous
republics and also to Europeans
who are building
commercial states,
other commercial activities.
It is in that context
that Woodrow Borah,
Brian Owensby have documented
for the 16th and 17th century,
William Taylor for
the 18th century
that overwhelmingly indigenous--
indigenous republic
to indigenous republic
relations had conflicts,
indigenous republic
and Spanish officials,
merchant conflicts were
mediated in the court.
And the ability of the courts
to mediate legitimated the
continuity of the regime.
So the depopulation creates
an environment, a true rarity,
I would say in modern history,
in which resources are scarce
for almost no one
for a period of time
and the regime consolidates
in that context.
Simultaneously-- and the
intersection may be even more
rare historically.
The opportunity of silver from
the 1550s created possibility
of profits for merchant
financiers, for mine operators,
for commercial estate
growers, and no shortage
of resources to do it.
But also we sometimes don't
recognize enough opportunities
to market produce
and gain wage income
for indigenous peoples inside
and outside the indigenous
republics.
And in that context, society
of Spanish Mesoamerica is
integrated by an ancien regime
that used negotiated processes
of petition and mediation
to balance interests among the
powerful and used the courts
to mediate disputes among
indigenous communities
between indigenous communities
and states and merchants,
et cetera, all backed
by exceptionally limited
and uncertain militias.
I have almost gotten-- it
is so regular for scholars,
students to just-- it's a
language that comes to all of us
so naturally, the Spanish
forced, the Spanish coerced,
the Spanish made it happen.
And I say, wait a minute, tell
me-- They may have ordered,
they may have mandated but
find me the coercive power,
where is it in the
neighborhood that that happened?
And I haven't gotten
many answers
that it's actually there.
Something else is going
on and I'm searching
for a way to understand it.
All right.
That hybrid ancien regime, my
argument is, sustain an economy,
I increasingly describe
as silver capitalism
by the 18th century.
And in Mesoamerica, I want
to emphasize, particularly
in the core basins around Mexico
City, my Mexican Heartland,
that silver capitalism
was also a hybrid.
Finance, commerce concentrated
in the capital, in the city,
as did the wealthy
families leading mining,
landed entrepreneurs, they're
concentrated in the oligarchy
as capitalist as any in the
world in the 18th century.
The distinction, in the
Bajio in the regions north,
the subject of my Making
a New World, this is owns
with few landed self-governing
native republics.
Commercial capitalist
ways, the new economy,
shaped life all the way to
the base, top to bottom.
From the 17th century
through the 18th, mineworkers,
tenant-growers, wage
workers in fields
and factories including
the thousands of women
in the great tobacco
factories in Mexico City
and Queretaro live
in a commercial--
I think rapidly becoming
capitalist society.
But in the Mexican heartland,
the Mesoamerican heartland
at this point, outside
the city and mining towns,
the vast majority
of the population,
90% live in indigenous
republics,
speaking indigenous languages,
Nahuatl or Otomi in most cases,
through to the end
of the 18th century.
While their populations had
been low and lands were ample,
late 16th through
the 17th century,
people of the republics had
basically had the capacity
to sustain themselves and
to take wage supplements,
market earnings at mines in the
states providing for the city.
After 1700, population
begins to grow,
land becomes less efficient
but not radically
scarce in the republics.
And it becomes less possible
for families and communities
to maintain the autonomous
production of sustenance
that had marked them
post-depopulation
through the 17th century.
But in the 18th century, as
Spanish entrepreneurs took
over the commercial
production of indigenous crops,
indigenous crops, maize and
pulque, were primarily produced
by indigenous community
based growers
through the 17th century.
From about the 1720s, major
landed entrepreneurs based
in Mexico City took
over production of--
commercial production
of maize and pulque.
They took over the
Mexico City pulquerias.
And they create-- while
they profit wonderfully,
their capitalist utopia,
they offer increasing amounts
of wage labor at their estates
to sustain families
and communities.
So, people are capable, are able
and they do remain residents,
vicino, citizens of the
indigenous republics.
They produce sustenance
to the extent they can.
But as they can't, they
increasingly cap the income
of the commercial economy
through some marketing,
but ever more through
wage labor.
And in the process, it
sustains the republics
and their families.
And in fact through the
18th century, subsidizes
and sustains a growing
commercial silver capitalism.
They're actually essential
to its endurance
and profit ability.
Simple characterization
of a complex problem.
Production of silver,
the-- international trade,
the internal commercial economy
and regime revenues all
grew more than four times
over in the Mesoamerican
regions of New Spain from 1700
to 1800 while the population
a little more than doubled.
And what is too often
not recognized,
in the Mesoamerican heartland,
stability held past 1800.
There is no major
destabilizing challenge
to this regime until 1808, 1810.
The break I argue came in 1808.
It came in May in Spain.
It came July to September
in Mexico City,
when in the reverberations that
came from Napoleon's invasion.
Politics were militarized
in Spain and in New Spain.
And the militarization
of politics came coupled
with claims of popular
sovereignty.
And I will simply say, that
has set me to thinking a lot
about a rethinking of the
19th and 20th century.
But that's a new and different
history and I'm just going
to say thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Ralph Bauer: Thank you, John.
We are running a little bit
late but maybe we have time.
We'll just take a couple
of questions and then go
to a very short break and then
continue with the second panel
after about a five-minute break.
So, are there any questions or?
Please.
>> Right. I have
three questions.
First question for you.
And I was [inaudible] between
this race and this
pulque, just--
It's about Bartolome de Alva.
You-- do you--
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah, yeah.
>> Regarding Bartolome and
I would like to ask if you--
if you could comment more
because he is a mestizo.
>> Joan Bristol: Yes.
>> So think about--
>> Joan Bristol: Right.
>> -- this [inaudible].
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
>> The second question
is for you, Garry.
The link between the theology,
theology of liberation
and this theology of
enculturation in the Mayans of--
And, John, the last question.
And what's the role of
religion and of the lack
of secularization
in the [inaudible]
of the ancien regime
till beginning
and last years of
the 19th century?
>> Ralph Bauer: OK.
Joan, do you want to go first?
>> Joan Bristol: Well, maybe
you could help me think of that.
I mean, so Bartolome de Alva
was a mestizo and he was--
I mean, I-- he was writing this.
He wrote this confession
manual for--
>> He's a priest.
>> Joan Bristol:
Yeah, he's a priest.
Yeah. And he wrote
a confession manual
to be used among the
Nahua speaking people.
So, I guess he-- I think
he was really talking--
the way-- my interest in him I
guess is the way that he
is sort of distinguishing
between the Nahua people in
the past and the present.
He's not really talking
about mixing.
So, he-- I mean,
so you're saying
because he himself is mixed and
sort of what does that mean.
>> For us.
>> Joan Bristol:
Yeah for-- Yeah.
>> At least for us.
>> Joan Bristol: Yes.
>> I don't think he comes with
[inaudible] he's a priest.
>> Joan Bristol: Uh-huh.
So, you're-- so, you're
saying-- So what--
So he considered himself
as a Nahua or as a--
>> As a priest.
>> Joan Bristol: As a priest?
OK. Yeah. All right.
So, you tell me.
So, what do you think
the implications are?
>> No, I don't know [laughter].
I was very interested
because we--
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> Bartolome de Alva--
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
>> -- is a priest.
>> Joan Bristol: Yes.
>> And he's a sort of mestizo.
>> And he is the
brother of [inaudible].
>> Joan Bristol: Yes.
Yes.
>> Supposed to be Indian or
a Spaniard, but just in front
of these people talking
about this topic--
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
>> -- and adding all of this
problem of defining themselves.
>> Joan Bristol: Right.
Right. Right.
>> Or not defining themselves.
>> Joan Bristol: All right.
>> I have no answer.
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
Yeah. I don't have
[inaudible], but well,
that's a-- That is a good way.
I mean, that's very interesting.
I think I-- Because also
the way he sort of functions
in my paper is he sort of tacked
on to this discussion of mixing.
But then really, he is
saying something different.
So, I think I need to think
about the connection really
between those two parts more.
So unfortunately, I don't
really have an answer either,
but it's a very interesting
question.
So, thank you.
>> Perhaps I've been--
>> Joan Bristol: Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
No, that's a very good question.
Thank you very much.
I'm sorry I can't really
address it further.
>> Garry Sparks:
So, the relationship
between liberation theology
and enculturation theology
particularly in New Spain
or Latin America-- Turn it on.
I don't know.
Oh, I'm sorry.
It's a great question because
there is oftentimes I think a
false understanding that
there's these three movements
within current Latin America
and Christian theology initiated
after Vatican II
liberation theology.
And then, there's this
conservative reaction against it
which is the Catholic renewal
or the charismatic theology
which comes about a bit later in
the 1980s and then the offshoot
from liberation theology
particularly around 1992
and the counter-protest
in Columbus' anniversary,
the 500th anniversary by
indigenous people, the emergence
of enculturation theology.
But yet if you look at
the local paper trail,
really enculturation theology
begins prior to the Second
Vatican Council in
places like Chiapas,
the Dominicans mid 1960s,
liberation theology would
be much more clear in 1971
and then charismatic renewal
also began simultaneous
to liberation theology and
doesn't acquire a conservative
sort of dimension to it
until late '70s and early
'80s, but they're all
in concurrent relation--
movements rather than sort of
splintering off the main trunk.
The main distinction
though liberation theology
and enculturation theology is
liberation theology is first
and foremost concerned
with class analysis.
So, that's the primary
sort of locus of oppression
that needs to be addressed.
Indigenous peoples found that
they find that rather racist.
And so, reading early
sort of [inaudible]
by say Leonardo Boff
really sort of tip a hat
to gender oppression
or ethnic oppression.
For many indigenous
peoples, once said to me
by a [inaudible] colleague,
I'm poor because I'm Maya.
I'm not Maya because I'm poor.
And then for them, the primary--
the sort of the super structure
of oppression to put
it in Boff's terms,
Marxist terms is racism and that
the class oppression is really
more of the infrastructure.
And so, they sort of flip it.
And they also think that
the liberations theology--
agenda has a bit more
of an assimilationist.
Most of the advocates for
liberation theology come up
with liberal political
wing of Latin America
which typically wants to sort of
assimilate and build in which--
into mainstream indigenous
people which has a tenor
of ethnocide for many indigenous
activists who are trying
to actually preserve some
[inaudible] other culture.
So, there's-- in that sense,
they're somewhat shared
with the common discourse
of [inaudible],
the elimination of hierarchies
[inaudible] of egalitarian
horizontal structures as opposed
to vertical structures,
political, economic, ecclesial.
But the ways that they think
are the roots of the problem,
diagnoses, and then
prescriptions
for that [inaudible].
I don't know if that's
the question but-- OK.
Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> John Tutino: Very easily--
Religion, if pivotally central,
I could easily make it
the third hybridity.
If I argue for a
regime hybridity
and economic hybridity,
certainly there is a
religious hybridity embedded
in all of these.
And I'll first escape
the question
with the highest
praise I can think of.
It made no sense for me
to add that hybridity
because that is the issue that
Serge Gruzinski has addressed
in such great depth and
detail for New Spain.
I don't have much to add there
other than to learn from you.
But I'll characterize my view
of this right now in two moments
in a pretty broad
overly general way.
First, looking at the end of
the 16th, early 17th century,
the moment on which I
see this system sort
of consolidating
for the first time.
And two things come
together there
that have really struck me.
If you look at the
communities, almost everybody
in the indigenous republics,
they're not speaking Spanish.
But in the areas certainly
anywhere close to Mexico City,
everyone is taking Cristiano.
They are self-defining
themselves as Christian.
At the same time, the
clerical discourse,
shall we say the tired
missionary class,
is writing about their failure.
They have not created Christians
in their definitional sense.
And to me, that mixes
everything,
that indigenous peoples
have adapted, evolved
and consolidated their
vision, their understanding
of what Christianity
is and should be
as it's meaningful to them.
They're developing their
devotions to virgin, saints,
the cofradias that sustain
them, et cetera, et cetera.
And at the same time,
it is pretty clear
there was a resistance
to European notions
of sin and morality.
So it is a very much hybridized
religion that I have just come--
and I use it in the plural
indigenous Christianities.
There may be one
for every community.
This is not a broadly
shared reality.
And that the whole system had to
live by the religious hierarchy
and the regime learning
to accept all
of that diverse hybridity
at the local level.
The classic best known
example of course is we know
when devotion to Guadalupe
emerges in the regions
of Mexico City, it is
resisted by the powerful
for the earlier century
and there's a point
in the mid 17th century where
it can't be resisted so we might
as well adapt and
promote, et cetera.
And the regime goes forward
in that mixed negotiated
hybrid way.
And then I'll just add,
get to the 18th century,
and here you have
what [inaudible]
so clearly the Magistrates
of the Sacred.
Yes, bourbon reformers wanted
to impose a new more moralizing,
more true Christianity
on the communities.
And what he found were
letter after letter written
by those [inaudible]
saying, if I do that,
they won't pay my fees.
If I do that, they'll
run me out of town.
I cannot do that.
I have to accept
the Christianity
that is-- that is there.
That's my short tale
of the third hybridity,
but it is very much
a hybrid too.
>> Ralph Bauer: OK,
may-- one more question.
OK, please.
>> Does the hybridization of
the religion in the 20th century
impact the Indian community
as it slides, you know,
adapt their agricultural
technology in Guatemala?
>> Garry Sparks: I'm sorry.
I missed the first part
of the question, sir.
>> Does the hybridization
of religion
in the Indian communities
impact the efforts on the part
of the Indian community to move
towards the new agriculture?
>> Garry Sparks: I
don't-- I don't think so.
I mean, I just say, I'm
reticent to sort of buy
into anything distinctively
hybrid
about the Christianity in, say,
Mesoamerica, Guatemala given the
fact that we put up a Yule tree
around the Roman Saturnalia
festival Christmas and look
for Easter eggs on the
fertility festival.
Easter--
I mean, Christianity is kind
of a hybridity, all going down,
right, sort of all going
down in that sense.
So I'm not entirely convinced
Maya have ever really been doing
things different than say Celts
in Ireland or even Palestinians
for the past 2000 years,
Palestinian Christians.
But no, I mean, if you
can look at things like--
I mean, just probably
like as interesting
as the text is [inaudible]
where she talked
about her father working
in the Peace Corps
in order to implement new
sort of farming techniques and
yet she is trying harvest
a particular distinctively
indigenous identity with about
13 of her chapters beginning
with epigraphs, The
Book of Rule.
And so I think for many of them,
I think they're negotiating a,
you know, both modern
technology, modernity
today just as they were
negotiating modernity
with cofradias and
[inaudible] 500 years ago.
And many of the-- particularly
say 1950s, 1960s authors
that are bringing in--
some agents that are
bringing in modern technology,
Maryknoll priests
are also bringing
in liberation theology, right.
So [inaudible] cardamom
production in [inaudible] and
yet sort of what's happening
with also Jesuits in that area
of enculturation theology.
And of course, Guatemala is one
of the larger producers of--
and exporters of
cardamom [inaudible].
Yeah, very politicized
liberationist
or you can say [inaudible],
very active with Jesuits,
and so they're combining
Christian identity,
that might be.
So I don't think
they see them anyway
that is mutually
exclusive necessarily.
Are you-- Is there a
particular concrete example?
>> Well, I was thinking the
fact that in the 16th century,
indigenous community, a lot
of different indigenous
community I know begin to look
at the use of fertilizer
in a different way.
And I think that was a part of
their ability to see fertilizer
from a different vantage point
in terms of what was happening
in relation to [inaudible]
because at one time, it was
very difficult to get them
to change their survival
agricultural habit.
I mean-- Right.
So that's what--
>> Garry Sparks: I think it also
have to do with the local sort
of political tension
particularly in that period
with the introduction
of Catholic action.
>> Yeah.
>> Garry Sparks: And trying to
break the sort of political--
>> Absolutely.
>> Garry Sparks: --
stronghold of the cofradias
which would see themselves
as traditional even though,
you know, their traditional
sense
in the 1550s or in the 1580s.
So I think in some way, that's
much more of a political tension
between those principalities
that voiced
up specific religious
hierarchy and those
that are more trying to confirm
a more merit-based way of
the socioeconomic access
of power and circumvent that.
It gets couched in
religious discourse
but I think it's much
more of a political.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.